let's move on to the crypto corner yeah
crypto as we all know
is taking over it's taking over society
it's taking over fortune 500 companies
big banks are getting involved in crypto
and now sports
in america is getting taken over by
crypto did you hear
what happened in la david no tell me oh
my god
do you know where the lakers played you
know where the clippers played you know
the la kings play staples center they
did play at the staples center
now pardon me in the next month
the staples center will now be named no
the crypto.com
arena
that is david just walked off the show
he is pissed no because he didn't say we
were going to talk about that
[Laughter]
uh you have the link david sorry we
could pull the picture
right now
so for the last 20 years since 1999 so
21 plus years crypto.com the lakers
in l.a clippers as well i think they're
getting their own arena too
um and the la kings for our hockey fans
have played at a place called the
staples center bonus points for where
they played before the staples center
bonus points before the staples centers
no no clue they played at the great
western forum where mike uh michael
where magic johnson used to ball out the
forum yeah okay there it was so if you
ever watch those so now the staples
center is going to be renamed the
crypto.com arena so this is the
richest
the richest
naming rights deal
in sports history 700
million dollars do 700 divided by 20
real quick uh the naming the the 20-year
naming rights agreement makes the
singapore-based crypto.com the official
cryptocurrency platform of the la lakers
in the la kings 100 million divided by
20. 12. yes yes 20 by 20 by 20. sorry 35
million 35 million bucks a year is what
they're paying jesus bingo bango it's
funny to crypto.com it sounds like what
an old person how an old person would
try to learn about bitcoin yeah
what do i do just go to crypto.com
that sounds like a joke dude sounds like
a joke it's a 700 million dollar joke
right not a joke at all not a joke at
all they're taking over the richest
naming rights deal with my grandfather
history 700 million our friend david
over here did the math 700 divided by 20
35 million
bucks a year wondering if they're paying
that in cash or in bitcoin so you know
how much
uh the staples center 20 years ago when
they did their deal they signed for 20
years 1999's a little over 20. they paid
120 million
okay wow 100 to 120 divided by
20.
uh so they they got the naming rights in
1999 six it's six million dollars a year
so 6 million 20 years later is now 35
million a year real estate that has
appreciated that is appreciated that
staples center is now the crypto dot com
center and just like perfect timing
perfect timing the name change
will take place
on christmas day
december 25th
while the la lakers take on the brooklyn
nets so during that game christmas day
biggest day in the nba other than the
finals biggest game
exactly biggest games
crypto.com coming to you live from
thecrypto.com arena let's hear your
announcer voice who wants to do it
coming to you live from the crypto.com
arena
yes yes there it was
so now uh jeff have you heard of this
crypto stuff jeff now i have heard of it
james it does seem to be some sort of
witchcraft i do think so as well i think
it is witchcraft let's focus on the game
i think that's right there goes lebron
james
so you know lebron's going to get
involved in this
he's going to be playing at crypto.com
you don't think they're going to have a
little lebron i don't know i've never
come out i've never seen lebron in a
staples commercial you know what i mean
i don't know how close these people are
to this well because staples aren't
exactly that cool yeah yeah crypto.com
is yeah
let's talk about how uncool staples is
little takeaways for you whether you
like it or not
crypto's coming into your life whether
you like it or not it's coming to you i
don't like crypto i live in la i'm not
messing with crypto uh where's the game
tonight crypto.com arena
there it is okay i can't escape it yeah
i mean that bubble is closing big time
heat fan
love miami heat my dad took me there
since 1988 when i was a little little
young boy just sitting on his lap at the
game
now the american airlines arena is now
the ftx arena yeah a different
competing
crypto exchange to crypto.com ftx owned
by
billionaire 29 year old sam bankman
freed
uh
absolute genius
so miami used to be american airlines
now the ftx arena la used to be the
staples center soon to become crypto.com
mlb have you not seen
ftx all over the world series ftx was
everywhere
okay premier league you're a soccer guy
yeah do you not see with etoro all over
tottenham and southampton and new castle
these teams yeah not seen etoro
okay but now it's crypto
stamford bridge to the goddamn ethereum
stadium that's the day
football died
[Laughter]
but it's common man so you talk you talk
joked about staples you never saw lebron
in a staples commercial little i did a
little fact checking on staples
obviously they're known for office
supplies heads school supplies pens and
uh
it's a stapler it's a stapler for all my
friends that's my favorite spanish word
by the way they've been a struggling
company it probably wasn't the best
investment for them to invest
into the staples center 20 years ago 20
years ago i'm telling you right now
since 2017 they went from a public
company to a private company they got
sold yeah they're struggling their
numbers have been going down staples is
the best
crypto
is the future staples american airlines
i mean they're replacing a lot of big
companies that have been around for a
very long time
i'm no expert but i might put some money
in crypto now huh
i mean it does seem to
that's what i'm saying that's with all
these stories like it's legitimizing
bitcoin yeah bitcoin could not be more
like we're there we're there yeah it's
all right people are second guessing
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauz cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken